bonjour bonjour nordine vous avez
reconnu bien sûr nordine à table
monsieur sports du journal de la santé
sur france 5 qu on voit aussi d'ailleurs
sur france 3 nordine tulle cg plus de 50
ans je suis un homme qui est fait de
sport par le passé j'ai besoin de me
remettre
j'ai choisi donc la course à pied le
running comme on l'appelle aujourd'hui
est-ce que d'abord ce choix est
judicieux et comment faire pour me
remettre sans risque mais ce qui est
bien déjà avec la course à pied avec le
running comme tu le dis c'est qu'on peut
s'y mettre à n'importe quel âge alors
l'idée bien entendu c'est que et bien au
départ on est voir son médecin pour voir
si on a pas de contre indications et à
partir de man où on n'a pas de problèmes
articulaires musculaires ou tendineux on
peut se relancer
allez on fait l'exercice le 1er c'est
parti alors on y va donc le premier
exercice on va renforcer notamment les
quadriceps
alors on l'a tous fait cet exercice
l'exercice de la chaise pas besoin de
matériel
juste un mur voilà donc là on va
travailler essentiellement les
quadriceps non on peut voir ce joli
quadriceps ici là c'est dur comme de la
barre à mine et puis au bout d'une nuit
tu vas sortir des petits picotements ça
va commencer à chauffer après les très
exactement
donc là aussi il n'y a pas besoin
d'aller sur trop de temps l'idée c'est
d'adapter d'adapter la durée par rapport
à son insu capacités et là on va
travailler ce qu'on appelle notamment
les quadriceps donc l'avant des cuisses
même si après en plus sur un petit
travail des des fessiers donc là les
genoux sont serrés les pieds sans serrer
le bassin est très haut
d'accord est ce que tu vas faire c'est
que tu vas crever les pointes de pieds
pour être en appui sur les talons paf
et comme j'ai été sportif et bien on va
relever une jambe et au maintien
une seconde et on change qui alterne on
lève le job parfait avant d'attaquer la
course à pied on va voir comment mais
peaufinées l'échauffement pour prévenir
notamment les blessures on va se placer
à la noc la up
le corps droit et on ramène un talon
près du fessier d'accord voilà
par contre les gentils tu vas me le
faire de façon dynamique oui monsieur
les parties avec les bras de talons
fesses qui vient en direction du fessier
super et là tu vas pouvoir avancer super
donc là on évite l'écrasement bien
solide en pointe de pieds c'est parfait
pas de nom pour une 4l c'est plutôt bien
en fait c'est une ferrari écoute je
pense que je suis prêt je te remercie
pour tous les conseils
j'en ai retenu certains me faire plaisir
parce que c'est important quand on
reprend le sport
il ya aussi le fait qu'il faut
s'hydrater parce qu'il fait chaud en ce
moment dernière chose j'ai retenu
effectivement qu'il faut pas partir sur
un marathon immédiatement y aller
crescendo mais je vais faire un petit
tour en bord de loire ton coeur plaisir
merci nord bien lucas john a